Well Dave and I are here today to talk about Patrion.
And so I'll start.
We've been engaged in lengthy series of email exchanges with all of the people
in our network,
and no one is happy at all with what's been happening.
And so we've been determining what our options are and we looked at subscribes
to our,
but it looks like paypal decided to cut funding out from them.
And so it doesn't look like moving to an alternative provider and an alternative
commercial provider that's out of our bailiwick,
out of our control is going to be viable.
So Dave,
why don't you describe what we talked about today?
Yeah.
Well first I think we should just make it very clear for everybody how
significant what happened to Carl Benjamin Sargon of Akkad is it doesn't matter
what you think of him or whether you agree with him or any of that stuff.
The banning of him for doing something that was not on the patrion platform that
wasn't even done on his channel because of a word he said,
where he was using the word against the,
uh,
the alt right or the Neo Nazis or whatever you want to call them,
is a massive move of that line of what's acceptable.
Now there's all sorts of debates we can have and we've had them of what lines
should be,
if there should be lines at all,
but the fact that this guy got booted with no chance of recourse with no
warning,
just just like that.
It's just an extension of everything else that we've all been talking.
I'm also,
and also given that it's also the case that he didn't break patrons,
rules of engagement,
the ones that they stated and that Conti had talked to you about the fact that
that wasn't going to happen and that Patrion hasn't responded well to this.
Well,
look,
Jack Conti came into my studio in my home and said he,
he said a phrase that I had never heard before.
Maybe you had heard it before.
Manifest observable behaviors.
So you had never even heard that phrase before,
right?
I thought,
I thought maybe this was just something that went past me.
Okay.
Now of course manifest observable behavior,
mob mob,
you can,
I mean that's,
there's a real,
there's a real there.
But,
but so the point was that it had to be about behavior and then in their terms of
service,
it also had to be about what was happening on platform.
So every firewall here of what would have been acceptable patrion failed.
And they've put us in a position where,
look,
I told,
I called you last Saturday and when this was really catching fire and I said,
you know,
Patrion is about 65 to 70% of my red that's,
I have a company now with,
with employees,
you know,
full timers,
part timers.
I was actually considering deleting it right then and there,
which no one in their right mind would do.
No business person would do.
And I've,
I've taken big risks in the past.
You know,
before I was on Patrion,
we were at ROTC.
I,
me and my producer and my director,
we all quit our jobs,
lost their health insurance all day to join patriots.
So I'm not,
I like taking risks.
But then I realized,
all right,
we have to figure out a plan and that's exactly why we're doing this,
right?
Yep.
Yeah.
Well,
and we would've moved faster,
but we,
well,
and I did set up a subscribes to our account,
although I never quite finished setting it up,
partly because subscribes to our seem to fall apart almost immediately under
attack.
And,
and also it wasn't obvious that I also read their terms of agreement and it
wasn't obvious that we weren't going to be just in exactly the same situation
again.
And there's only so many mistakes you can make before the mistakes start to
become fatal.
So we want it to come up with a serious and,
and,
and stable solution.
And I've been working on for months,
literally for months,
it's been six months.
I've been working on a system to allow authors and other people who engage
publicly on intellectual issues to interact more effectively with their readers
and viewers.
And listeners,
and it occurred to me this week that with a bit of modification that that could
serve exactly the function that we're hoping would serve.
So what we're going to try to do as fast as we possibly can is to set the system
up on a subscriber model that's analogous to patron.
It'll have a bunch of additional features,
which I don't want to talk about right now,
and I don't want to over promise,
but the system is,
is because the system is new,
but we're going to try to get that rolled out as fast as we possibly can.
So,
and we have a number of people who are interested in hypothetically interested
in moving their,
their subscription service over to it.
Dave and I are very seriously planning to do this as soon as we can do it in an
intelligent way.
And so,
yeah,
you know,
by the way,
one of the interesting things here,
we haven't talked about this,
but I'm guessing your experiences just like mine,
the amount of emails that I have received and of course tweets and everything
else,
but most of the emails from developers,
from investors,
from regular people,
from engineers,
I mean just anyone going,
this is the one,
because you know the issue with all of these free speech things is it's like you
don't want to swing too early before you realize that the problems got into
critical Matt as,
but then most likely you're going to swing too late.
The blinds will have used so far that we may be on the outside of them.
And that's why this one I think was so interesting because Carl,
you know,
years ago,
five or six years ago when I started waking up to what was going on with the
left obviously,
and then all of the free speech stuff,
everyone said you've got to talk to Sargon of Akkad.
He's the guy.
So this is the guy that's been ahead of all of it.
Sorry,
go on to was like,
he was big.
He was very helpful to me when I was first under attack,
you know,
and he's a brave guy and,
and so,
and it's a real mistake what patron has done to him.
And,
and,
and as I said,
everybody in our network is extremely upset about it.
Like we've been sending emails back and forth while probably with 30 or 40
people.
And so as Dave said earlier,
we wanted to make this video today to let everybody that we're communicating
with know that we have not been sleeping on this front man.
People are trying to figure out what to do.
So this stops happening and,
and so,
and we have a good plan and we're going to try to implement it as soon as
possible.
So I would ask everybody who's listening to be,
you know,
reasonably patient.
Imagine that this will take somewhere between a week and a month to sort out
properly.
Oh,
we're,
we're going to try to get something up in the next week hopefully before
Christmas if we can't manage that,
you know,
cause when you implement something like this,
there are technical complications that might emerge that you don't foresee.
But I don't want people to get the impression that we're taking this lightly or
lying down and that we're not looking for a,
uh,
a permanent alternative because we are,
and I think we can come up with a better alternative.
That's the plan.
Yeah,
that,
that's exactly what I would say.
I would just add that it was like we were,
we were waiting for a moment.
You know,
we've watched these doors slowly closing on us.
All of us,
whether it's Twitter,
whether it's Facebook,
who's getting banned,
who's getting shadow,
banned payment processing,
everything else.
And we are taking this as seriously as possible.
Of course,
you know,
Jordan,
who's working harder than anyone on the face of the planet.
Somehow you managed to also partly build a platform over the course of the past
year.
In the middle of all of that,
I knew that this,
we knew that this was lurking in the background and that this was going to be a
problem.
Dave,
you've spent lots of time talking to investors and developers about building
alternatives to these platforms that seem to be willing to throw their weight
around in an increasingly arbitrary manner.
But it's not like it's a simple thing to
do.
People want somebody to say enough is enough.
And I mentioned this in a live stream I did the other day,
but you know,
I've watched my patrion drop.
We've lost around 600 patrons,
I think about 5,000 bucks a month.
But in a weird way,
I've actually been inspired by it because I'm watching.
Yeah,
great for themselves.
So it's like on one hand people are emailing me and they're saying,
I'm dropping my patronage and I'm really pissed and it's not about you and I
want to support you.
And on the other hand,
my business side is going,
that's not great.
But you know,
but we will,
we will solve this thing.
I have nothing way.
I've lost a thousand subscribers and I feel exactly the same way.
It's like,
well,
they're telling Patrion to go to hell.
And you know,
it's,
it's not so good for me on the financial front,
although that's not too big a catastrophe at the moment.
They're,
they're taking the right stand and,
and encouraging us,
let's say,
or encouraging someone to do something about this.
So anyways,
what I like,
I like what you said.
If we can just ask you guys to be reasonably patients,
we're talking to everybody that you can think of and some people that you can't
think of.
We're going to fix this.
Yeah.
Well we're going to,
or at least we're going to do our best to fix it.
There's going to be some bumps along the way,
man,
because we're now,
we have to speed this process up to,
so you'll have to consider this a Beta version,
but at minimum,
we hope to provide,
uh,
an easy way of switching to a new subscription service within the next very
short while.
And so and thank you everyone for your continued patients and your continued
support and your attention and your thoughts and your reaction to all of this.
And,
and it's,
it's very much appreciate it and it does help us,
I would say maintain motivation to continue doing this constantly.
You know,
the fact that I have all these patrons subscribed certainly is one of the
reasons that I tried to put my youtube channel.
I wouldn't say first and foremost because it's had to take a backseat to this
lecture tour,
but men,
it's way the hell up there on my priority list.
Absolutely.
And it gives us all sorts of flexibility to do all sorts of things.
It gave me a little bit of flexibility to join you on this tour.
So I'm incredibly humbled and appreciative of everybody that does that.
Fjord and I will,
I will see you in a couple of days in west Palm beach eating steak.
I will take you out for a steak.
Good,
good,
good.
Well I found a good steak place here so we'll will,
I'm looking forward to seeing you,
Dave.
[inaudible] the touray cause we're going to continue the tour in,
in,
uh,
California.
Yup.
Great.
Three venues in California in January,
and then the two in Australia,
New Zealand,
and we're going to add additional dates and hopefully soul and Singapore,
maybe the Philippines.
We've got all sorts of additional things planned.
We doing anything on the moon.
Well,
uh,
not so far,
but uh,
but I have some connections to logon basket.
Okay.
Now we'll talk to you soon.
We'll get this up right away.
Great.
Okay.
Bye.